let's go next to Moni from the United
Kingdom Moni welcome to the program
what's on your mind today
oh yeah I actually just got back from
work I love the show I just want to say
keep up the good work well welcome thank
you
um so I wanted to bring something up
that uh it's been playing on my mind for
a bit now and I never really saw anyone
bring it up and it's when Biden did the
State of the Union Address fairly
recently yes
um no one seemed to point out that when
Biden brought up the
whole idea of funding the border patrol
officers actually getting the money and
equipment that they deserve and they
need
um on the CNBC news station it actually
cut to Ted Cruz and his reaction he was
sitting there shaking his head and
complaining and I just don't get why
oh uh it's I mean I don't know how
familiar you are with in general how
it's a complete partisan show but yeah
yeah it's mostly that I mean it's you
know that that's what people like Ted
Cruz have to do they have to complain
they have to shake their their head they
have to ask act disgusted even about
like uncontroversial things
yeah I mean it's just such a shame
because
um I mean clearly that's he always says
that the Border needs to get more
funding and more equipment and stuff
like that and and then as soon as it's
proposed he sits there and shakes his
head like that you know yeah like who he
is but so she doesn't see that it's
pathetic it's what it's what his voters
expect him to do and he's not a serious
person that's the reality
listen can I ask you a question I'm
curious if you have some insights I'm
soon going to be making my triumphant
return to the United Kingdom and I'm
going to have the opportunity to spend a
little bit of time on the south coast of
England you know where Brighton and
Bournemouth you know the area yes yeah
if I had the opportunity to choose any
place to spend a few days in that area
is there a particular spot you would
recommend like is Brighton better than
Bournemouth or what where would you go
I I haven't really been too uh
Bournemouth in my life I'm I'm kind of
almost between Brighton and London okay
that's where I live but I go down to
Worthing and Brighton quite often
Brighton's really nice
um it is what a lot of us like to call
the LGBT capital of Britain for the most
part or the south of Britain anyway oh
really well those spots usually have
some of the better food scenes is that
the case in Brighton as well Brighton
does have a lot of good food options
that's interesting yes and it's right on
the water correct yeah it's right by the
beachfront depending on where you stay
in Brighton of course maybe Brighton is
a good place to check out that's
interesting yeah Brighton's always the
the go-to beach area I think I'm not
going to speak for all people from the
UK but you I would I know you would
never do that you would never all right
good I'm gonna look into that I
appreciate the advice but no I I love um
I've been looking a lot into U.S
politics recently and you've been doing
some good work out there so thank you
for all that I appreciate that thank you
so much yeah thank you have a good day
all right Monie from the UK folks let's
end it there because we couldn't
possibly end on a higher note we will
take calls again and I hope to hear from
you next time